a third-generation shrimp brewery he's
lost everything with this spill I've
been riding this boat for 30 years to
change the frames new job is working
with the burn team but finding a good
patch of burnable oil even on a clear
day is difficult from the low vantage
points of the ships but back in Houma
Louisiana help is on the way
a jet departs Tenace Airport
heading to the rendezvous at the site
burn team crew members on board shrimp
trawlers supply vessels and an oil rig
diving boat unspool hundreds of feet of
boom these are floating fireproof
curtains that extend above and below the
water corralling the oil into pools for
burning
from the air Narae 'mobile an engineer
with BP will guide the ships to patches
of oil 'mobile is callsign is spotter
one
this is spotter one
I'd like you to turn right about 15
degrees so that you can get your boom in
the right place over our plan for the
next hour two hours is to vector them
into the oil that we found here team two
this is spotter one 'mobile directs a
pair of shrimp boats led by trawler mr.
jug to a nearby slick and captain now
turn left about ninety degrees within
minutes captain Dufresne and the team
find what they're looking for
Roger that they've pretty much got it
all around right here's part of one
thick black oil
the two trawlers will drag the boom
across the surface of the water to
collect the oil teen 3 mr. joke you're
doing a good job skipper you've got to
get into some heavy oil you got some in
your boom and I think you're ready to
light or I'd rather have shrimp in my
nets but under the circumstances all
will do